this is where we left off in the last
video we followed these steps to get the
square root of 8281 as 91 now let's try
solving for the square root of six
thousand and eighty four before we start
off with the steps remember to draw
lines like these next to the number
after this go to the first step we mark
pairs from the unit's end so we draw
bars over 84 and 60 so the two pairs we
have are 60 and 84 now we look for a
perfect square which is equal or just
lower than the first pair the first pair
is 60 since 60 is not a perfect square
we look for a square closer to it 49 is
a perfect square close to 60 so is 64
but remember we choose the perfect
square closest and just lower so 49 is
the perfect square we are looking for
and we have to write the square root of
this perfect square here we know that 7
squared is 49 and hence we write a 7
here you should know that finding the
first number is the most important step
of this process if we go wrong here then
the rest of it will definitely be wrong
in the next step we multiply above and
write the product here so 7 x 7 gives us
49 and then we add below and draw a box
next to it 7 plus 7 gives us 14 and we
leave some space for the box next we
follow out three simple steps
subtract product 16 - 49 gives us 11
then we get the next pair which is 84
down then we draw the same box above and
below and at last we reach our favorite
step finding the digit in these boxes by
trial and error we want the product of
two numbers to be equal to 1184 but the
product will look something like this
and we have to use trial and error to
find the digit in these boxes okay now
here's a trick you need to remember this
trick can be used only when there are no
more pairs left here since 84 was the
last pair we brought down we can use
this trick we know all the boxes contain
the same digit and any digit from 0 to 9
can be in it that doesn't mean we try
all digits one by one starting from zero
until we reach 9 look at the unit's
digit of the result we want
it's 4 so the product of the two digits
in the boxes must have 4 as the unit's
digit so we narrow down our
possibilities to just two choices
2 times 2 equals 4 or 8 times 8 equals
64 both have the unit's digit as 4 it
will either be 142 times 2 or 148 times
8 the digit in the box will either be 2
or 8 the first product gives us 284 and
the second product gives us 1184 exactly
what we wanted the digit in the boxes
will be 8 after we find the digit in the
box
we go back to the third step we multiply
above 148 multiplied by 8 equals 1184
and then we add below 148 plus 8 gives
us 156 then we subtract the product we
got from the number above it 1184
- 1184 equals 0 we stop since there are
no more pairs left in the number the
number at the top is the square root we
get the square root of 6 thousand and 84
as 78 how do we check if our answer is
correct one way is to multiply the
answer with itself and see if we get the
original number the other way is
interesting this number here will always
be twice of the answer 156 is 78
multiplied by 2 in the previous example
to 100
32 is the double of 91 wait a moment
what if we had five digits in our number
after choosing two pairs only one digit
will be left we will see an example
based on five digits in another video
you